most techniques are complicated because
um we think we know what we're
we're watching and then we try and do it
but it's not quite
it's not quite as as you see it
if my you can't see most of you can't
see where my hands are
I can't do the foot bring them forward
because they're pinned at the back I
can't lift them up I can't go into him
I'm pretty much in we'll say a bear hug
so this right hand
the right hand I'll just show you this
is going to make an entire Chi it's like
a bird's beak all right it's a bird's
beak so I'm going to put all my fingers
together
I'm now turning on my cheek
but I can't move him so I can't move it
a centimeter my buttock turns as the
bird beak turns I don't know how many
people can see it but if I keep there
it's starting to come out at that time
this hand needs to have crept over to
there so now it's keyhon because I've
got one hand on it now I can make it
come out I mustn't make it come out
until then
now this hand's going to come here and
if I had a can to cut cut him
that would do that and that's where I'd
end up
it's the same as the cadetadori one
I can do this one it doesn't matter
if I have a um an open hand let's go
this way if I have an open hand
it's difficult to turn it if I make a
bird's beak
it's easier
if it comes out before I've got my hands
closed then it's not keyhon and he can
take his hand away
so
we've got another technique for that
so birds beak turn
it comes out too quick he takes his hand
away never mind
all right so there's always another
technique
so if you find you mess up do the arimi
bird's beak
if you think about it
you perhaps didn't see that earlier
the camera will have so I can't lie I
didn't go like that
I actually went
I said that thumb goes over there and I
was closing my hand up because I know I
was
foreign
so all right so there's a piece more to
add to it the bird's beak this is in in
Tai Chi
you know you hit these points
on the person's body
we won't go into that we're doing I
could aren't we okay